hi my name is Noah and I have a weird
obsession with government memos sort of
like my favorite literary genre
I love reading them because the world is
an unclassifiable place but the people
that write these memos have to try to
classify it anyway
and the results get weird you get these
sort of like classification oddities
these regulatory platypuses this comes
up especially often in tax policy so
you'll get a case like a state where a
Snickers bar is taxable but a KitKat bar
is tax free because the Snickers conses
candy but the KitKat bar has flour in it
so it counts as a baked good instead in
California there was a case in 1950 with
the Board of Equalization it's maybe the
least appetizing court document you'll
ever read it's about whether a sausage
casing should be considered a food or a
container don't think about it too much
here's another one
if your child is kidnapped can you still
claim them as a dependent on your
federal tax return it was someone's job
to figure this out and now publication
final or the three-part test that you
have to me my favorite government memo
of all time is from the state of
Wisconsin
it's about ice cream cake and whether it
is a cake or ice cream this memo is
1,500 words long it contains 10
different hypothetical ice cream cake
scenarios that it walks me through but I
I recently learned that in my new home
state of New York there's a special tax
category for sandwiches
so this meant of course that somewhere
there was a memo defining the official
New York definition of a sandwich so I
had to find it I found it it's tax
bulletin 835 I think it has a long list
of examples things like BLTs and club
sandwiches and penes but also some kind
of questionable inclusions like gyros
and hotdogs and buttered bagels it
includes open-faced sandwiches which
strikes me as really dangerously broad
like we're just gonna call any piece of
bread with stuff on top of it a sandwich
you know should we be considering a
slice of pizza and open-faced grilled
cheese seems like a dangerous path
but the thing that actually this was not
the most troubling the most troubling
thing in there is that burritos are on
the list and I know in my heart that
burritos do not belong on this list
right but I had trouble articulating why
and it kind of led me to a lot of
soul-searching about what what is the
essence of Sandwich ness you know what
is it that really defines a sandwich is
it stacked layers is it about being open
rather than enclosed does it need to
involve two slices of bread for that
matter doesn't need to involve bread at
all if you want to get Talmudic about it
there's the the halal sandwich that's
eaten on Passover which uses matzah
there's the Ice Cream Sandwich is that a
sandwich in name only I don't know if
KFC still makes it but there's also the
Double Down which strikes me as very
sandwich like so I have spent a lot of
time lately thinking about sandwich
hypotheticals in case that wasn't clear
but for the burrito issue we actually
don't have to be hypothetical there's
some case law on this from right here in
Massachusetts so in 2006 a Panera Bread
signed a lease in a shopping center in
Shrewsbury with the clause that
basically said no competing sandwich
shop would be allowed into the mall
while they were there a Qdoba Mexican
Grill moved in and Panera sued their
landlord and argued that they sold
sandwiches the judge the spirit court
judge ruled emphatically that a burrito
is not a sandwich and what I want to
draw your attention to is that the the
defense case included testimony from
three expert witnesses there were three
sandwich experts like the Boston chef
who said I know of no chef or culinary
historian who would call a burrito
sandwich the notion would be absurd
there was a food writer for the Boston
Herald who said nobody would say that
they are going to the burrito shop to
get a sandwich or conversely that they
were going to the sandwich shop to get a
burrito I have agreed the star witness
was the former deputy director of the
food standards and labeling Division of
the USDA who pointed out that while the
USDA regulates burritos it doesn't even
have jurisdiction over sandwiches
so there are actually two separate
regulatory frameworks the FDA handles
sandwiches so it seems it seems like
there's an emerging expert consensus and
that New York may be sort of out of step
with it I filed a Freedom of Information
request for the New York State
Department of Taxation and Finance and I
hope you get some more clarity on this
but it's still pending so in the
meantime I will leave you with an
argument that I find an oddly persuasive
which is the torta defense and the tort
of defense states that if a burrito were
a sandwich it would be a torta and a
burrito is not a torta ergo a burrito
cannot be a sandwich thanks
[Applause]